[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about how
to use the singular value decomposition
to solve a linear system of equations ax
equal to B even when a is not a square
matrix namely we do this using the more
penrose pseudoinverse here a dagger and
we've been talking about underdetermined
and overdetermined systems of equations
where in general you either have
infinitely many or no solutions of these
equations but I want to be a little bit
more mathematically precise about
exactly what are the conditions on the a
matrix and the vector B so that you have
no solutions a unique solution or
infinitely many solutions now this goes
back to some linear algebra that we've
probably all learned but might not have
sunk in the first time around or at
least it didn't for me okay so I'm going
to walk you through these four
fundamental subspaces defined by the
matrix a so I'm gonna you're probably
going to remember the column space and
the range and the kernel and the null
space and all of these these words that
you've heard in linear algebra classes
and what I hope to do is to make it all
come together and make sense in terms of
when this matrix a the system ax equal
to B actually does or does not have
solution okay that's going to relate to
when when you can get exact solutions or
when you can only get approximate
solutions okay so remember that the
solution of AX equal to B I'm just going
to write it over here the solution of a
x equals B only exists if so if and only
if B is in the column space of a B is in
the column space
of a and we're gonna denote this column
space literally by column of a and I'm
going to say what this means again so if
I have ax equals B then what we're
trying to do is find some vector X so
that if I added up the columns of a in
that linear combination it would equal B
now clearly that's only possible if B is
in the span of the column vectors of a
so there are you know in this case of
the underdetermined system it's highly
likely that B will be in the span of the
column space of a but I could certainly
cook up a terrible example a counter
example of a very degenerate a matrix
where it's not true that B is in the
column space of a so for example I could
kept up cook up bad a which is equal to
1 1 1 1 1 1 and a corresponding B vector
which is equal to 1 2 now I think it's
pretty obvious that there is no X vector
possible that can multiply this a matrix
and give 1 2 because 1 2 is simply not
in the span of these column vectors
because I chose them to be degenerate
because this only has one direction in
the column space in the one one
direction and B is not in that column
space so this has no solution even
though it's kind of this short fat a
matrix I chose a really really bad short
fat a matrix where this is not true now
even in this case of the over determined
system where usually I don't expect my a
made my B vector to be exactly solved by
a X if B was one of the columns of a so
that it was in the column space of a
then there is a solution to that so if I
had a equals 1 2 3 and then let's say 2
3 4 and if B is equal to 2 3 4 then this
is trivially solved with x equals 0 1 if
I take 0
one times that a matrix I get B again
because B is in the column space of a so
these statements about it under
determinant over determined systems are
generally true but there are certainly
some column vectors B where there is a
solution even for over determined
systems and there might be some under
determined systems where there are B
that that don't have solutions okay so
both can exist and it really depends on
this column space of a so that's really
really important as the column space of
a now there are three other subspaces
that are important there's what I'm
going to call the orthogonal complement
so this column of a sorry I let me go
back column of a this set of all vectors
that can be written as a linear
combination of the columns of a is also
equal to the column space of U by
construction I constructed the singular
value decomposition this is the economy
SVD specifically so that this column
space of U hat is equal to the column
space of a that's called the range okay
so that's what those words mean now the
next subspace is called the orthogonal
complement and it's kind of everything
else that's not in the span of a and
we're gonna denote this by the kernel of
a transpose I'm not gonna talk in detail
this actually all follows section 1.4 of
our book data-driven Science and
Engineering so if you want more details
just go there the link will be in the
comments and this space is the
orthogonal complement to this column
space of a so there are vectors B that
are in the column space of a and there
are directions perpendicular where if
that vector B was in that orthogonal
complement there would be no solution
okay and this covers the whole column
space the whole RN the vector space RN
given by the columns of a now for the
row space we similarly have row of a is
the set of all vectors that can be
spanned by the rows and
a and again by construction that's equal
to the row space of V transpose which is
the column space of V okay that's pretty
useful and then the last subspace I'm
going to talk about is the kernel of a
and this is known as the null space this
is the set of all vectors X this is the
set of all vectors X such that a x
equals zero okay it's a very very
important set it's all of the vectors X
that map to zero by multiplication with
a ok so for example in this example the
vector 1 negative 1 is in the null space
of this matrix because that maps to 0
good now we're ready to talk about when
there are no solutions one solution and
infinitely many solutions so the only
way I'm going to have a solution of ax
equals to be an exact solution is if B
is in the column space of a ok so that
guarantees that I will have a solution
if B is in the column space of a and if
B is not in the column space of a if it
somehow has some component that's that's
outside of that column space then I will
no matter how hard I try to find an X
there will not be an X that that exactly
satisfies ax equal to B as in this case
ok now if I want infinitely many
solutions so if I also if also the
dimension of the kernel of a is not 0 so
if I have a non-trivial kernel which
means that there are some vectors that
map to 0 then there are infinitely many
solutions
then infinitely many
Solutions and the way you can see this
is for example let's call this vector X
null this is a vector that gets killed
when it multiplies by a then what I can
do is I can take a solution a solution
vector that we know exists and I can
just add a null vector that null vector
to it and when I multiply by a I get ax
which is B plus a times X null which is
0 and so this is also a solution and so
if there are any vectors in this null
space in this this null space of the
kernel of a that mapped to 0 then there
will be infinitely many solutions X to
the system of equations and that's
usually what happens in this
underdetermined case is that this a
would have a big null space and B would
be in the column space of a and there
would be infinitely many solutions ok
and if B is not in the column space
there's no solutions which is often what
happens in this overdetermined case but
again it's a little bit more nuanced
than that there are some cases and
underdetermined where there's no
solutions there are some cases and over
determined where there are solutions or
even infinitely many solutions and all
goes back to this kind of column space
null space range orthogonal complement
that we all learned in linear algebra I
know when I learned this I was spacing
out looking out the window and it was
only much later when I learned about the
singular value decomposition that I
realized how important this was to solve
ax equals to B ok so next we're going to
talk about how to use these solutions
for linear regression problems which is
how we build models from data so it's
the foundation kind of a starting point
for machine learning ok thank you